love it unlvino is entering its 49th
year and they have a new twist to
celebrate their bon vivant series is
back with five events this year and here
tell us more this is Shania Graham I'm
sorry and also we have Chris Matson the
general manager of Al Salito posto
welcome you guys hi welcome thank you hi
thanks for coming back to the show so
let's talk about the series what is this
series what is going on so we took the
kova time to take a little break and
redo unlvino and kind of jazz it up so
it's a series of dinners that lead up to
the big Grand tasting the bonvavans and
it it's donated 100 back to the school
the students work in the class they're
part of the dinner and we host it at
different restaurants our first one is
with Chris and Chris what can we expect
at the restaurant this year so we I'll
see the poster are known for handmade
pasta we're partnered with Chef James
trees he's the owner of our restaurant
as well as Esther's Kitchen downtown so
we're going to start lighter bites we're
going to find malpack oysters from the
north and Atlantic okay some arugula
salad after that we're gonna move into
Italian Classics we have House made
meatballs with veal and beef a little
ricotta cheese good night absolutely and
everything is paired with a different
wine of course and how do you guys come
about with the wine and food pairing
um well we get our suppliers involved
like this time around we have antonori
which is a renowned Winery in Italy
multiple wineries in Italy and uh we
pair it with the food sit down and taste
through the food and taste the wine and
make sure everything goes together well
I love it I love you and Oviedo it's an
annual tradition you're there drinking
wine having a great time but this is
even extra special because it's an
intimate Affair you can sit down with
your friends you can enjoy the wine but
now you're enjoying delicious food as
well and there's a what's the charity
Italian that's connected to it goes back
to the hospitality College okay because
there's always students working and
helping as well have you guys been to
you how many years have you gone to UNLV
now I've been working it for 15 years
yeah this is my first event I'm really
excited is it you want to be such a
great time now this is the first series
what's the next series after the first
one
um the next one is going to be at
Delmonico's okay so it goes on and on up
until you know it's gonna be a blast
thank you guys so much for joining us uh
Las Vegas now we will be